[Música]
economía información importante para su
bolsillo y los mercados aquí en france24
está con nosotros en el estudio jorge
hurtado jorge hay preocupación en méxico
porque un producto básico como es la
tortilla ha sido afectado por la
inflación que afecta a la economía de
ese país que dicen allí santiago las
tortillerías en méxico enfrentan un
significativo aumento de los precios por
la guerra en ucrania y el encarecimiento
también de los insumos en mexico los
precios de la tortilla de maíz fueron 17
42 por ciento más caros que hace un año
durante la primera quincena de abril y
de hecho son más del doble de la
inflación general del 7 72% interanual
de ese país la tasa más alta en 21 años
para darnos una idea hace dos años del
kilo de tortilla costaba 15 pesos
mexicanos o unos 75 centavos de dólar
pero por la inflación ahora cuestan 20
pesos mexicanos o casi un dólar si lo
aterrizamos a la mesa del hogar
significa que por la misma cantidad de
dinero una familia está consumiendo
ahora entre 10 y 12 tortillas menos que
antes la tonelada de maíz costaba antes
de la guerra unos 345 dólares pero ahora
los tortilleros la encuentran en unos
445 dólares para los dueños de estas
populares tortillerías lo único que
pueden hacer es lidiar con el malestar
de la clientela por los altos precios
escuchamos
la crisis del clima le ha golpeado
la sequía ya menos cuesta más
aunado al conflicto
ha vuelto loco
santiago frente a esta situación el
presidente de méxico anunció el plan
anti inflación de precios de garantía
negociando con empresarios para
controlar 24 productos de la canasta
básica lo que incluiría al maíz ya la
tortilla por ahora este aumento de
precios es un gran golpe para los
mexicanos que según el instituto de
ecología hay el consumo per cápita del
75 kilogramos anuales lo que equivale a
casi 10 tortillas diarias por mexicano
bueno la tortilla por las nubes seguimos
analizando el impacto de esta guerra en
américa latina' no me diga que también
la arepa y la pupusa también se deba a
incrementar el precio jorge es muy
probable de santiago pero bueno vamos a
hablar ahora de eeuu siguiendo con
nuestra serie especial sobre los efectos
de la guerra en américa esta vez vamos a
ese país allí desde marzo se prohibió la
importación de productos estrellas rusos
desde entonces reconocidas y lujosas
marcas como la firma de diamantes
tiffany han cerrado sus puertas a los
bienes de consumo ruso a los negocios se
empiezan a notar la falta de algunos
productos nuestra corresponsal mamen
sala nos cuenta más desde nueva york
[Música]
marisa es experta en diamantes
lleva más de 20 años al frente de este
negocio los anillos de diamantes los
hacemos aquí pero el diamante viene de
canadá o áfrica
sabe por dónde ha llegado su producto al
país pero imposible descubrir de dónde
han sido extraídos los minerales la
teoría es que rusia podría estar usando
una tercera nación para introducir sus
piedras preciosas en eeuu luego de la
prohibición que hiciera joe biden a los
productos rusos después del ataque a
ucrania
este país de entrada podría ser un día
donde se pulen y cortan el 95% de los
diamantes del mundo
no sé exactamente de dónde vienen pero
sí sé que son 100% diamantes en una
situación similar se espera que ocurra
con el pescado y el marisco rusos que
entrará en este país a través de china
para que se hagan una idea el año pasado
según la comisión de comercio
internacional el 50 por ciento del
cangrejo rojo importado a eeuu procedía
de china pero fue capturado en rusia en
el 2021 eeuu importó productos
extranjeros por valor de más de 2 183
mil millones de dólares de los cuales
3000 millones procedían de rusia
alrededor de un 11% como estas patas de
cangrejo algunos propios y uno de los
mariscos más populares que llegan de
rusia eeuu este tipo de cangrejos
siempre llega a congelar gracias a que
se distribuyen congeladas todavía hay
existencias pero poco van a durar locos
los proveedores locales tienen mucho
inventario que viene congelado por lo
que por ahora no hay problemas para
conseguir el producto pero seguimos
preguntando qué va a pasar y nadie tiene
una respuesta en ese momento le tiene
claro que en sus estanterías no habrá
productos rusos infiltrados detectar que
no está disponible no podemos ir a la
fábrica y hacer más tenemos que lidiar
con ello una falta de producto que
impactará directamente en el bolsillo
del cliente en todos los sectores ahora
con la prohibición de entrada de
diamantes rusos los precios pueden
aumentar aún más sólo por la demanda son
los efectos de una guerra que aunque
está a miles de kilómetros de distancia
afecta a todo el mundo incluyendo a las
propias exportaciones rusas
otro frente afectado por la guerra
muchas gracias jorge y ya estamos listos
aquí en directo américa para el debate
[Música]